字幕提供
布林通道跟抓娃娃又有什麼關聯咧
擋板呢就有點像布林軌道的帶寬
擋板低呢就比較容易出
- 讓我們看這隻網...
- 這樣就掉出來了
- 喔...
- 欸...
- 看到沒有
- 哇...
- 布局
- 表示這些菜貨
菜貨不要
- 頭包率太低
- 爪子有力
- 就跟股票一樣
- 籌碼有主力
- 有主力的話
- 股票比較容易噴出
小哥
- 陸裡才當秀幹嘛把我預帶外面
- 因為我要帶來抓娃娃
帶我來抓娃娃
不是我們是財經節目
我們是股市達人
來抓娃娃幹嘛
抓娃娃跟股票有很大的關係
有什麼關係
抓娃娃我們要看廣時有沒有利
股票我們要看什麼
有沒有主力在裡面
對
籌碼有沒有主力
抓娃娃有些技巧
股票選股也有些技巧
選股也有技巧
而且那個娃娃漂不漂亮
這個股票值不值得買也有技巧
沒錯
如果小哥膽敢帶我來抓娃娃代表一件事
小哥股票做那麼好
娃娃一定抓得超厲害
在台灣才好
比不上那些YouTube
不過在日本就比較會抓一點
聽說小哥在日本啊
他是在每個機台上面都有小哥的照片
只人不准來抓喔
造成我們巨大的損失喔
所以小哥今天竟然敢跟我約在外面抓娃娃
想必跟投資有很大的關係
什麼關係呢
今天我們要交的叫做
不靈通道
好現在網友滿頭問號
不靈通道跟抓娃娃又有什麼關聯咧
我們賣個關子
因為小哥要跟我走進去
我們一邊抓一邊講給你聽喔
走吧 小哥
好 走
小哥我要那支 我要那支
你要那支
我要買那一檔
待會夾看看
好
這個娃娃已經算很漂亮了
對啊
因為一般娃娃機店看不到什麼漂亮
標骨
好
那假如是那些菜貨
菜貨不要
因為我看過那個娃娃機
10塊錢叫你夾個那個飲料泡麵
怎麼樣
這台不一樣
頭包率太低
這台也還不錯
那工具要怎麼看呢
工具我們就看這爪子
爪子不要太歪斜
太歪太斜的容易把抓到這容易再丟回去
爪子要正一點
正一點會比較好
再看這爪子有沒有力
有沒有力
那我們先看這爪子有沒有力
要待頭前來知道
爪子已經先裝了爪套
裝爪套的摩擦力會比較大
就比較容易抓起來
所以這是個良心機台就對了
目前看起來應該是個良心機台
因為還沒投錢不知道
所以爪子有沒有利
跟你剛剛講主力籌碼有沒有利很有相關
對 這個爪子有利就跟股票一樣
籌碼有主力
有主力的話
這個股票比較容易噴出
爪子有利呢 這個娃娃比較容易加出來
好 所以接下來就是技巧的部分了
還有 再來
然後再看這個擋板
擋板
這擋板就有點像布林軌道的帶寬
帶寬
布林擋板越低
這個娃娃就比較容易跳出來
比較容易跳出來
價格比較容易向上或向下的跳出來
對 價比較容易噴出或是往下跌
原來如此
那如果擋板很高就像布林帶寬很寬
對
補教就在這邊混
所以這個算高還低
這算很低
算很低 好好
所以等一下我們的娃娃會噴出就對了
對 看起來應該是容易噴出的
好
那我們準備來夾看看
準備來夾看看
剛換了一千塊
一千塊嗎
好
一千塊再換一千塊好了
好 試看看
我們現在夾一個簡單的
簡單的是不是
現在夾一個這個
哇塞
這個
看到了耶
立馬夾出來
會不會太快
因為它擋板地下就容易噴出來
這種小東西是很簡單的
我不要剛剛那個嘴魚
那個標的普普
那我們看這隻
欸欸欸欸欸欸
那隻掉出來了
哇
哇 小哥
我猜太大了
哇
送你送你送你
抱個牌給我啦
抱牌
對
抱娃娃
抱娃娃比較好啦
抱牌容易
我們要怎麼選標的
這個是我喜歡啊
喜歡的
你要選一個看起來值得抓的標的
看起來值得抓的標的
就看這個
第一個娃娃喜不喜歡嘛
第二呢
看這個娃娃的抓點多不多
抓點多不多
一般你看到圓滾滾的
但是都不好處理
最好是有手有腳比較好
有手有腳
圓滾滾很多放在那個
這個位置我們叫槍位
很好抓的位置叫槍位
圓滾滾放在槍位很多都在騙你錢
就像很多主力
他會故意好像讓你覺得
這檔要漲了
很容易漲 都在騙你
所以我們看主力籌碼其實在賣
對
所以我們要抓娃娃
要去找那種
最好是這個有手有腳的
因為你的臭點會很突破
而且有手有腳比較容易突破
對 不會光溜溜的
那我們再裝一隻有手有腳的
好 那我們來抓那個
米老鼠
老鼠呢我們先把它拉到槍位一下
好
這力道真的很不錯
好啦好啦
沒關係
那我們還是拉一下
看這個小鈴鐺能不能下來
幫助我們一下
好
哇這種就是用勾的
根本沒有夾阿
對對對
拉拉拉拉拉
來對對對拉拉拉
好喔
已經到了
拉的過程中
會讓他的
台面的布局產生了蠻大的變化
那待會呢
待會我們夾這次就有機會了
來
因為待會它夾起來
夾起來之後它有可能會碰到
哆啦A夢
它就很容易跳出來
因為現在看起來它的賣壓很重耶
賣壓
它被哆啦A夢壓住了
很沉重的感覺
不錯不錯
對不對
很有梗
來
好
看到沒有
哇
這叫布局
布局先把胖的拉過來
它就會卡在那邊抓起來
碰到它就會掉下來
這個中間是問題的
小哥這就是你本來要買A
結果後來B賺比較多的意思嗎
不是這樣子的
好
這叫布局就是
獨立在誘惑閃戶出貨的一個手法
不過這個抓在中
我看也是有點機會啦
好
哇
很抓沒有機會喔
因為它的
這個
頭很大
好
我現在全包看看好了
我先全包看看它會不會出來
這個爪子的速度比我以前小時候玩覺得快很多欸
對
以前我還可以慢慢弄個二三十秒的
對 因為它需要你頭前更快一點
你知道嗎
這樣會不會有
來
等一下
你看
我覺得他很有力
小哥我現在發現不是夾娃娃跟投資相
是你真的投資要賺錢才有本錢夾娃娃
小哥你女朋友一定很多
因為你那麼會抓娃娃又那麼會做股票
女朋友交往的時候
那時候娃娃是變成小娃娃
現在可以交了啦
不要嚇我好不好
就是喔 剛剛
不要害我
我們已經釣到這麼多
勾到這麼多好的標的了
所以這個爪子很重要喔
因為等一下我們進棚就會講了
這三根爪子分別就在
布林通道裡面
一根是頂
一根是中間的均線
一根是它的底
那小哥剛才抓的技巧呢
如何運用在布林通道上面
我們等一下進棚就可以
來慢慢的告訴各位網友們囉
請我們一起來進棚吧
你看 登登
我們哥有仇必爆就回到棚內了
剛見識到小哥夾娃娃的功力
可是聽說小哥覺得台灣的台子
實在是困難度比較高
台灣台子蠻夾多的
給各位看一下
我在日本的戰利坪
那這張圖片呢
是去日本參加一個
9900塊的團
那個團不是夾娃娃團
那團他也是有帶你出去跑行程的
去哪邊啊
去佐賀
左賀的阿嬤
對 你也聽過左賀的阿嬤
我們夾娃娃最忌諱的就是去市區
最喜歡的就是去那種鄉下地方
就是阿嬤多的
阿嬤多的
娃娃就多
因為阿嬤也不大會夾
阿嬤夾一個回去她也很開心
不像我們這種看到好夾的
會把它夾回來
這個好可愛喔
那個團是四天三夜
然後都在同一個飯店
夾娃娃
都住那個飯店
那飯店走出去步行
步行有兩個店
走15分鐘內可以到
在佐賀車站
那邊叫Rounder 1
Rounder 1蠻好夾的算是比較有良心的店了解第一天夾這些你看小弟當 哆啦A夢這個 對好可愛而且日本娃娃看起來好精緻
對 質感好多了
對
這是第一天晚上夾的
第一天晚上
第一天晚上剛熱身
因為剛下機場
剛熱身
這樣才剛熱身啊
對
哇 好多隻耶
還有寶可夢的
來
來看第二天
這是第二天
第二天台子比較熟了
大概知道怎麼夾了
所以第二天夾了這些
台主沒有跑出來揍你
他們沒有台主這種東西
沒有台主這種東西
他們只有場主沒有台主
因為他們就一個場子
就同一個公司在看的
場主可能想
我鄉下地方發生什麼事了
對啊 後來去夾發現變男夾了
可能我的照片
有被貼在他們的店裡面
嫌疑犯
對 看到我要把那個台子挑來
大家可能不曉得喔
我們現在理財達人秀哥有仇必報
我們會擺一些娃娃
都是小哥夾來我們現場擺的
對 超級可愛耶
這樣夠了啦
第二天夠了啦
你都沒有床可以睡了
對 後來我們第三天
講說要回家了
第二天要加個破百再回家
你睡哪裡
你睡地板
這個第三天
隔天要整理
這個排出已經半夜兩三點
這個密集恐懼症
你團員知道你在做什麼嗎
團員你是來批貨批娃娃的
這個你要自助還帶不回家
這叫跟團
因為跟團
你有遊覽車可以幫你載娃娃
所以遊覽車上面的那個放行李
全部都放我們這些娃娃
而且最厲害的就是
聽說江湖上有一個傳說
會夾娃娃的人
在股票操作上特別厲害
為什麼
因為布林通道的秘技
就跟夾娃娃秘技一模一樣
所以小哥布林通道
聽說就是小哥用的最厲害的一種工具
沒錯 我們來看布林通道
先來講 江湖傳言要出現了
為什麼勒
抓娃娃與股票的相關性
對
抓娃娃兩個條件
是
第一個爪子要有力
爪子要有力
這台灣的機台就稍微
台灣機台有的爪子都沒什麼力
對 鬆鬆的
不大會浮
第二個最好是低檔板
低檔板
是指娃娃要掉出來的那一個檔板
那個檔板越低的話
它隨機跳出來的機率比較高
勾一下就下來了
對 高檔版的話
有時候就要拼隨機保夾
在日本叫隨機保夾
對 在台灣就是你要投到保夾的速度
什麼250啊 300啊
台灣很多都1980
蛤 1980是夾什麼
他們叫大貨
大貨
事實上拿回去可能沒那麼好用
大貨 對
但日本隨機就是有一次夾子會變緊就對了
對 那個隨機其實
你觀測還觀測得出來
對
它要在變緊的那前幾次
會稍微緊
所以我們有時候都坐在高點
然後看一下有沒有稍微緊
稍微緊差不多了
然後我們上面的人就會跟我們講
那一台快出了
我懂了
所以小哥你等一下要教我們
就是布林通道也有保夾
所以小哥會教你保夾
好
來看這買股票跟抓到一樣
股票第一個籌碼要有主力
就爪子要有力
對
第二個 股價呢 假如經過整理
布林帶寬窄
對
那這種呢
你看它往上翹
對
你就要去買
看它往下
你要賣出
或者是放空
好 所以布林帶寬窄
就是低檔板的意思
低檔板意思 股價容易表態
對 股價容易表態
那假如是那種高檔板
股價可能就在這邊混
它就比較不容易噴出
好
就這兩個條件
但小哥我必須先自首
我從來就沒有用過不靈通道
所以今天如果趙華聽得懂
所有的人都一定聽得懂
而且不靈通道真的江湖傳言
就是小哥用起來最厲害
不靈通道很好用
什麼叫不靈通道呢
不靈通道又稱為保利加通道
翻譯的不同
對 翻譯不同
又叫B-band都有
不靈通道主要有三條線
有上軌 中軌 跟下軌
就跟爪子有三根一樣
有三根 台灣三根
日本也有三根 有兩根
中軌它是定的是N天的簡單移動平均線
有人看到N我知道你又睡覺
我不是鼓勵不要睡不要睡
我有看那一集
N天我們通常都用20天
20天就月線
上軌就中軌加兩個標準差
不要睡
標準差我們在國中有教過
你忘了
我只有國小畢業
沒關係
兩個標準差你大概就可以記
那就是95%的機會
股價在上軌跟下軌線
中軌我們可以先設定是月線
月線我想很多網友們都會用
而且它也算是一個
比較中長期的線了
上軌跟下軌
如果大家覺得跟趙華一樣
兩個標準才很痛苦
就只要記得結論
就是常態分布95%的機會
股價應該會在這個通道以內
在通道以內
在上下軌線
但是坊間太多人講布林通道
我們看這個不靈通道
太多人講不靈通道
他會跟你講不靈通道很簡單
站上月線買進
跌破月線賣出
這個你不知道停損多少次
那我就看月線就好了
我還管它不靈通道
而且你會一直停損
站上買進跌破賣出
一直在停損
這跟小哥有一集我們講
48種K線不要用了
三種就好
不靈通道聽小哥的就好
對 沒錯 我已經把它歸納了
把不靈通道歸納成
最好用的幾個方法
最好用的方法
書可以丟掉了
看完這一集
你有不靈通道的書
好不好丟掉丟掉
小哥說交得太難
你會停損到爆炸
對 好 我們來看
來來來
問趙華 來
假如你站上買進
這個跌破賣出
站上買進跌破賣出
你看你要賠多少
哇 站上買進跌破賣出
站上買進跌破賣出
對
我就一直在做站上買進跌破賣出
你會停損到懷疑人生
我會停損到營業員可能愛上我
因為他手續費賺爆
對 可是他會覺得你快要離開他了
你一直賠錢
好 那這個呢
在整理的時候我們來看一下
它這部電通道有三條線
上面那個叫通道頂
通道頂 上面的線
通道頂在這個時候呢
通道頂是30.9
股價對不對
對 股價 30.9
通道底是29.9
29.9
我們一看 其實這檔股票
它長期就在通道頂跟通道底
這兩條線之間混
等於就是30.9%到29.9%
29.9%到30.9%
就3%而已啊
他在這裡混
你還要進去嗎
都不要理他
好 所以貸寬就是這樣算出來的
他貸寬只有3%
3%在這邊震盪
都不要理他
因為你每理一次
你的手續費交易稅
就要賠掉快0.6%
那當然就是給
都不要理他
什麼時候在理呢
只要布林軌道上軌往上翹
往上翹你要追再追
这边我要问了
小哥有藏一手
往上翹
往上这样也是翹
这样也是翹
那样也是翹啊
翹呢我们在
以前国中交我们都会叫它邪律
邪律
Y等于KS
这个我知道你又想睡觉
邪律呢
我们在国中的时候
我们会讲一些角度嘛
但是我们这边在讲股票的邪律
我们一律用%数来定义
听起来简单多了
對 因為你用角度定義是有問題的
對
我小時候看過一本股票的書
他跟我講
你看到月線往上翹30度的時候
啊哼
你要勇敢買進
對
都整效耶 30度
趕快把你的兩角氣拿出來
對啊 你這個月線你把它拉長
它整個變只剩20度啊
那你把它縮小 變50度啊
到底是要買還是要賣
對啊 角度會有時間長短的問題啊
對 後來就把那本書拿去墊湯了
因為吃火鍋電燈很好用
因為那個輸是騙人的
講那個角度幾度都騙人的
小哥又攻擊到了
角度幾度的通通輸丟掉好不好
小哥教你算對的
來來來
往上翹你看那個點在這裡
往上翹
對一點點
一點點喔
整理都不用理它
往上翹你再買
好
所以你會買的點會很漂亮
買這裡買在很低點
對
這股票是2019年最標的股票
所以小哥的意思是
只要這樣往上翹
往上翹都算嗎
往上翹就是個好買點
對
嚴上軌往上翹
往上翹叫開步鈴
它就是好買點
就這麼簡單
可是你還是要教我
你要看主力
最好是主力買
下面有一個主力買賣超
往上翹最好
就這樣子
我們這場課結束了
還沒啊
還有 後面還有
因為我現在有一個疑問
因為這個布林軌道看起來就是忽窄忽寬
對
忽窄忽寬
還有你還要教我算
往上翹多少才叫翹
對不對 對
好
那我們剛剛講的喔
就第一個方法
好
突破上下軌法
突破上下軌
往上翹
對
我們進去
好
往下翹
往下
往下跌就是往下彎往下彎我們叫它賣出好 往上翹買 往下彎賣出到目前為止趙華還跟得上好 那這個呢
主要是因為兩個原因
對 帶寬的原因
好 關鍵字出來囉 帶寬
帶寬腳很窄的話
對 那很容易它是會突破
對 帶寬腳很寬的話
它會區間震盪
所以有兩種玩法
對 主要跟帶寬有很大關係
好 帶寬
就這兩個玩法
那多少叫寬 多少叫不寬
對 這個我就要定義了
因為外面坊間帶寬太多定義了
聽小哥的就對
看不懂 看不懂
小哥教你 小哥定義都會定義到最簡單
小哥的帶寬定義
上通道除以下通道減1就可以了
就可以了
那你說這公事我看不懂
看不懂我教你 這個更簡單的
假設下通道100塊
上通道110
那我問你
100塊到110漲了幾%
10%
10% 對
你看一問你就知道了
漲10%嘛
那這種貸寬就正常
一般般
一般般就是台股
我有統計過
平均是10%
對
跟我們的漲跌幅
有很大關係
漲跌幅就10%
對
所以股價呢
就在這10%中間混
震盪
這10%中間震盪
這叫貸寬
好 所以正常是10%
正常是10%
那不正常呢
以下就很窄
剛剛有一個3%
3%窄到不行
5%以下很窄
20%以上就叫寬
其實它就是一個股價上下政府而已
差不多這樣的概念
所以小柯剛剛有講
如果很窄跟很寬各有做法
很窄可以來做突破
很寬就可以做區間
那怎樣叫窄 5%叫窄
有什麼股票很窄
有這一檔5903
全家
最近很多人在排隊當自己家
買口罩
全家就是你家
對
你看這次股災
你看它沒有
從220跌到217
蛤 這沒有跌啦
多無聊啊
這樣股票就很無聊
你看它每天都在那邊混
每天這樣混
每天就217到220
220到217
217到220
存股可能還可以
如果你坐價差的人
坐價差
你假如當充這檔賺大錢的
記得來找我
你是神了
是神是神
因为这种带宽才1.4%
1.4
它的上轨是220
下轨217
才3块
对带宽1.4
超级窄
怎么比喻呢
就像你的腰一样
赵华的腰
对你的腰超级窄
超级窄
超级细
好
接下来看我的腰
来看你的腰是吧
来看我的腰
不得了了
我的腰超级宽
超级宽
但超級寬很棒啊
宰相肚裡能撐船啊
超級寬可以做骨架
本來都不覺得自己肚子很大了
來上你們節目之後
還以為穿著襯衫很帥氣
結果看那快爆掉的鈕扣
太胖了
所以要開始減肥一下
我們要問網友
小哥要跟我進行一個挑戰
大家如果贊同的話
給我們加一好不好
小哥說他錄這個理財達年秀的
哥有酬必報要瘦10公斤
所以如果網友們支持我們這個計畫的話
留言給我們支持小哥瘦10公斤
那我們就每一期
我們來跟小哥PK
趙華要瘦5公斤
小哥要瘦10公斤
剛剛明明沒有這一段
怎麼突然跑這一段出來
好 因為你講到超級寬
超級寬
好 我要看我的體重跟你體重
是發散 收斂
好
應該我們不會再發散了
再看一下
好 來看超級寬
這檔叫做杜康
好 杜康
杜康他的通道底0.97
通道頂1.48
你看這上下差了幾%
從0.97到1.48
他就漲了53%
53%的一個震盪
53%震盪
所以這種震盪那麼大
到了底下你也不要再砍了
因為也跌50幾%了
也不可能不容易突破了
這個娃娃不容易夾出來了
沒錯 就是股價這邊震盪
好 所以像小哥的要那麼寬
就是超級寬喔
窄跟寬大家都聽懂了
那現在小哥要來進入到
郊學的部分囉
好 先從窄好了
窄怎麼用
好 來 我們來看這個
這個
胎布林 沿上軌
這個地方就會是個好買點
這個地方是好買點
原因是它是因為這邊很窄
然後發散往上的關係
沒錯
那我們做短線
做長線你就從頭包到尾就好
那你現在看是長這樣
你在當下看
你不曉得它會漲那麼多
我不知道明天多少 後天多少
你不知道
所以我們什麼時候賣
很多人都會問這個問題
因為買簡單
往上翹我們就買
什麼時候賣呢
各位 你只要沿著上軌都不要賣
沿著上軌
它只要黏在這個軌道上
黏在軌道上都不要賣
可是它這邊有離開軌道
只要一離開軌道
一離開上軌我們就賣掉
一離開上軌就賣掉
等於是剛剛那個小哥有講
他可能翹起來
等一下小哥還是會教我們翹起來怎麼算
然後就沿著上軌
可是一離開就賣掉了
對 一開就賣掉
我們的這個買一點跟賣一點
他只要有一點點黏住都還好
對 一點黏住就可以
好 一離開就賣掉
離開上軌可以部分挺利
所以不見得要全賣
不見得全賣
因為你可以留幾張
留幾張以後給兒子看
你看老爸這一檔賺了800%
我只有一张的就卖掉了
只有一张就卖掉
那不然呢就是
这个一突破
一突破呢你就买进
好所以小哥这边是因为
他这边又变窄
然后突破再买进
对突破买进
这个突破买进
突破买进一离开卖掉
玩短线就这样
很简单
很短对
对很简单
没错那最好是
这个阻力有在买超会比较好
来再来看大雪光
好
所以也是一樣
這也很強的股票
只要一突破
一翹起來買進
這邊有離開就賣掉
一離開就賣掉
翹起來買進
一離開賣掉
就用這個方法
然後這邊小哥其實都有當主力買賣超
基本上主力雖然沒有大大買
但是好像也是買買買買買買
對
那主力再賣的這種股票就不要碰
即使他所謂的開後領了
也先不要碰
好 要搭配籌碼來看
好的 所以這個是很簡單的
如果他宰的時候往上翹就買
離開上軌就賣
這樣我還是可以理解
來看一檔我們最近有買到的股票
小哥有買到的東西好多喔
因為短線交易所以做比較雜一點
這檔叫亞光
亞光跟各位講個秘密
亞光他們喜歡開
喜欢开
不是喜欢
他们每年都会开望年会
望年会就是有点尾牙的意思
对 尾牙的意思
我以前以为望年会
是开同学会
望年 忘记得望
又不是啊
他们是那个兴旺的望
对
望年开尾牙
通常开尾牙前后
股价都还不错
所以亚光每次这个尾牙
我都会注意一下
尾牙什么时候
那这次尾牙是1月初
1月初
那股价在12月都就反映
因為聽說老闆喜歡在尾牙的時候
講一些公司的好話
激勵人心
明年賺多少
股價容易噴
對 做一波
做一波之前
關鍵分點先買
什麼關鍵分點
不能講
不行 小哥
敲碗敲碗
你們的收視率太高了
那是因為小哥來
影片一上線十幾萬人看
連關鍵分點都在看
他看了之后他就跑掉了
他说我的分点被发现
请亚光的关键分点自己来留言好不好
自己承认自己跳出来人是你杀的
我只要讲了之后他就搬家
就不准了
所以关键分点还是不要讲
好没关系总之
这边有关键分点
关键分点先买
然后呢主力买超
这个就是一般有的免费软体就有了
对这个很多软体都有
那这边各位看一下
股價往上開布林
股價就翹起來了
這邊其實小哥有幫我們算
它就是布林通道大概5.4%
符合亨載嘛
對 它這個往上翹之前
才5.4%而已
符合亨載
那今天特別教各位一個東西
叫做斜率
斜率
對 因為往上翹
有的人往上翹
翹幾度才叫翹啊
對
翹幾度叫翹
這個
這個小哥為什麼講起來怪怪的
我突然想到這是財經台
對 我很正經
我撬幾度就要撬
問你老婆
不是不是不是
我不能這樣講
每個這一場都定義不同
定義不同
那我們來看
上通道價格
這個斜率
斜率我們就可以來算它到底撬多少
好
撬多少不是看角度
我們只要看
你看這83.1對8到84.7是就是從這個價格到這價格漲了1.9%這邊是看上通道
等於上通道從83.1%變成84.7%
這邊就有1.9%
漲了1.9%
1.9%符合小哥覺得翹嗎
1%就叫翹了
1%就叫翹
你對男人真的很安容
這不是財經
對 好 1%就叫翹
3%就很開心了
3%就很開心
我看過10%的
10%都腰你知道嗎
我看過10% 什麼叫10%呢
那個漢訊 四季剛
瘋狂的
每天都漲停
放空的很痛苦
一開盤先疊個
一開盤漲8%
標準的硬漢就漲10%
不補就10%
那個放空很痛苦
上通道協力很腰的就10%
3%以上就很強了
就很強了
1%就是男人
好 1%就算男人了
好 1% 協率1%就不錯了
小哥認證
好 你看他到上面
到上面你看這上通協率90.8%
93.7% 這中間就漲了3.2%
這就很翹囉
對 到這邊4.1%
34%就很強了
很強很強
那時候報自黨股票很開心
很開心 一路往上
一路往上
因為它的上通協率很陡
對
那報到什麼時候呢
只要報到一離開上通道
就可以了
所以你按照這個方法
可以到從80塊到105
小哥開心
老婆也開心
因為賺很多
賺很多
我們是財經台
好 證實了
貸款很窄的時候
往上好不好
協率一趴
然後就一路往上
可是如果股價離開
上通道的時候就要賣出
那小哥在亞光這一檔就見證了
84塊漲到105塊
沒錯
還有沒有例子
好 接下來教各位
上通道還有月線之間
假如股價都在這邊混的話
股價在上通道跟月線混的話
這叫多頭
股價在上通道跟月線混
還要不要管貸寬
不用
就不管貸寬了
因為這時候它的月線都是抖的
好
來 月線抖
各位請問多少度叫做抖
剛剛斜率是1%
對
那小哥那麼寬鬆
我們月線也給他1%
很好 你還記得
我們是算趴的
不是算角度的
我看書寫30度
那是爛書
這個極度
斜率多少叫做好呢
月線斜率大概0.4以上
0.4就好了是不是
0.4以上就很漂亮了
很寬鬆
1%以上就是很腰的股票了
好
假如股價在上通道之間
這震盪的話就要多頭
OK 因為基本上
它也沒有跌破月線
沒有跌破月線
基本上看月線的人
也是很輕鬆就可以抱住
對 中股票你就可以抱久一點
輕鬆抱 多頭走勢
那這個往下跌呢
這個各位看一下
你的賣點啦
當主力在賣的時候
重點是主力一直賣
主力一直賣 對
往下一開布林
布林下通道往下
也是彎一%嗎
彎一%也是一%
一%趕緊賣出
所以協力用在這邊就很好用
所以它這邊其實也是收窄
只是我們沒有在幫網友們算了
總之也是那種大概3 5%的
沒錯 沒錯 沒錯
所以它一開往下一開
只要超過1%趕快賣
趕快賣 趕快逃
這檔跌得兇耶
去年算跌滿慘的
來 接下來交
剛剛講的都是
我的結束了
現在交我的
現在交你的
我的大貸寬
有的股票它震盪區間很大
像星星
震盪區間很大
有多大呢
各位看一下通道頂
42.1
通道底34.6
他股價在34跟42之間混
這中間差了22%
22%符合了
20%以上就叫寬了
就叫寬了
就像男人
40腰就算寬了
就算滿寬的
我大概接近40
好
差不多40
我們來看一下
那這檔它是主力買超
主力買超
主力長期是買的
所以這檔主力買超
我們要做多嘛
所以在下軌就是個好買點
跟剛剛的概念不一樣
剛剛是破了
下軌往下彎
我們要趕快賣掉
可是因為這個主力一直買
大貸寬主力買
下軌是個很好的買點
我懂了
等於主力在逢低吸貨對不對
沒錯 很聰明
好 這邊真的玩友不要混淆了
不要混淆了 剛才是貸宅的時候
宅的時候如果你下軌到下萬你要賣喔
可是因為現在是寬貸嘛
寬貸代表他股票的震盪是很大的
所以主力如果在下軌買
反而是逢低買進的買點喔
你看這好像有沒有學起來
很厲害
因為國中老師的功利觀太厲害了
好 接下來再教一樣大貸寬的
好 大貸寬 然後主力在賣超
主力在賣超的股票我們要怎麼樣
要注意喔
要找賣點
其實主力的買賣超小哥看很重
看很重
其實關鍵分點也很重要
這是怎樣
關鍵分點拼命賣
你看這個很誇張
每天賣500張
精彩客的關鍵分點自己自首
因為小哥不講
上次有提到
因為他賣了所以可以提一下
這個各位看一下大帶寬
它的通道頂38.6
通道頂29.6
這中間差了30%
很寬
30%很寬了吧
然後再上軌
在上軌就是一個絕佳賣點
再上坡道
等於主力告訴你
馮高他要到貨了
你想想看他從下軌跑到上軌
也漲了30%了
主力拉了30%幹嘛
繼續出貨
拉30%出貨
因為主力砍到底
他要再砍
沒有人要接了
他出不掉
拉起來再出一次
就是等於坑散戶來跟
對 拉起來再出一次
這個點這個不會出現
它不會自首
因為很壞
各位你可以自己去查
就知道它兩分點
這個點我剛好有賣到
唉唷 小哥又剛好有了
剛好賣到
不是因為太厲害
是因為怎麼樣
本來就想空它了
本來就看它不順眼了
因為本來看主力賣那麼多
本來就想空
那一天空你不能用嘴巴喊
沒有 我要空 我要空 不行
因為你要空外媒卷怎麼辦
所以一早就先卡券
先把券賣在漲停板
結果主力居然拉到漲停板
賣出成交
一路跌下來
你看到
所以你假如賣在這邊
跌到下跪
賺30%
賺很多
所以小哥下次夾娃娃的費用
就全部交給你了
賺那麼大對不對
沒問題
可是我們剛剛看
你很重視主力
等於說每個步林通道的用法下面
一定要搭主力
甚至如果主力賣
即使布林通道看起來是好的
你也不建議進場
主力賣上面就可以空
上面就可以空
等於是反向
可是我要去哪邊才能找到免費的
免費的
就是我上面是布林通道
我下面要搭主力買賣超
因為關鍵分點你不講
有兩個地方可以看
第一個是籌碼黑線
免費的
手機上面都可以載到
這是APP
籌碼黑線在這邊
點一下這邊有個設定
底下就有個布林軌道
然後底下這邊有
主力買賣超的狀況
就看得到
就可以搭配的看
對 籌碼K線有
有的人他可能沒有籌碼K線的
或者是你用三組股市也可以
三組股市也是很普遍的一個
也是很普遍的
它在這邊有個MA
是均線
它原本是均線
你點一下
點一下這邊選B-BAN
B-BAN
那也是這個布林通道
它底下也是有主力買賣超
所以搭配著免費的軟體
然後搭配著小哥的說法
其實大家就可以主力買賣超
搭布林通道的用法了
好 所以我們今天這一集
好不好 大家的收穫
應該非常的大
因為小哥講了
今天也可以丟到很多的書
他如果教你算角度的書
你可以丟掉
他如果布林通道一直讓你
會一直停損一直停損的書
你也丟掉
聽小哥教的就好了
而且如果大家也喜歡夾娃娃的話
請記得布林通道的技巧
跟夾娃娃一樣
三隻爪子
看上軌 看下軌
看中間那條線
小哥設定是月線
窄的帶寬像趙華的腰
寬的帶寬像小哥的腰
各自有不同的用法
大家趕快來反覆的練習
那下一集小哥要教我們什麼秘技呢
我們有幾個主題大家聽聽看
放空的技巧好不好
全正的短線操作法
有沒有想知道的
趕快留言給我們
那我們的理財達人秀
歌有仇必報
我們下一集就再見囉
拜拜
字幕志愿者 杨茜茜